[Music]
Spiderwoman me
too are you uh oh this
we don't know the sex yet my husband
wants it to be a surprise he's really
corny but so hot will you adopt me what
what guys can we focus on the fire
breathing time of space
please what about her no we could use
the help no is it cuz she called you
dark Garfield do you say anything but no
no yes why not you know
why enough of
this take a good look at my
fire don't let him
out he'll disrupt the
[Music]
cannon
he better be of it it's
a go to the ground will you get out of
here have surrounded I'm a good guy you
don't look like a good guy you're just
going to have to shut up and TR me
[Music]
no
w
[Music]
yeah I think it's a b you like a cow or
a Dalmatian I
am the spot we meet again
Spider-Man oh that's funny to you of
course not no so is that a costume
unfortunately for both of us this is
skin oh dang you see I'm from your past
one year ago hold up oh come on uhoh
well this has been fun who you talking
to but I really got to wrap this up
going to be a while cuz I
can't okay let's do this one last time
my name name is Miles Morales I was
bitten by a radioactive spider and for
the last year and 4 months I've been
Brooklyn's one and only Spider-Man and
things are going
great you can hurt
somebody catching all sorts of bad
guys no can't you just act like a
regular super villain so I can catch
you I designed my new suit with some fly
Ambiance down the side Aunt May moved to
Florida done I guess off the Jeopardy
endorse baby powder apologize for
endorsing baby powder I made a mistake
my mustache came in
mustache and out I made another mistake
been developing a new Twist on my Venom
thing how much longer can I keep lying
about who I really am I hear that new
Spider-Man is Puerto Rican no seems more
Dominican to me I mean would they get it
if I told them we love you and accept
you even though you have to for
year maybe in some other
Universe sometimes I just wish I wasn't
the only
one I don't dwell
[Music]
on I miss my uncle sometimes M that's
see exactly what you doing there even
though he turned out to be the
prowler going try to do what he told me
going just keep going you're looking at
your text you understand this is the
fight of our lives right s sorry just
just a second man no no no no go ahead
take the call turn off your phone in a
movie theater if you don't turn it off
when you're fighting me oh in a minute
ah I wrote it all this one word cute
right the
youth that's
weird oh
no sorry I just I really got to be
some there's bubbles now hold
on I think this is going
great still bubbles on here you know I
think it's probably okay coming we're
figuring it out finding our
[Music]
rhym hey where the come
from I don't think think I want this
costume anymore almost there Mommy smile
your face is this your
good at the end of the
day I got you right where I so
aggressive I'm Spider-Man no one can
take that away from me unbelievable come
back to your Nemesis don't escape your
costume's too tight in the back by the
way
what are those claws dude are you sure
you're even
Spider-Man are you who do you think you
are
really my name is Miles
[Music]
Morales I was bitten by a radio actor
spider I'm pretty sure you know the r
jerk
[Music]
what's up
man you don't get it you're an anomaly
did you let me go
home
snitch everywhere you go you're an
anomaly
you're the original
anomaly the spider that gave you your
powers wasn't from your
dimension it was never supposed to fight
you there's a world out there with no
Spider-Man to protect them because it
been you instead you're not supposed to
be Spider-Man no you're lying I'm
Spider-Man you're a mistake
if you hadn't been bit your Peter Parker
would have lived instead he died saving
you he would have stopped the collider
before it ever went off spot wouldn't
exist and none of this would have
happened and all this time I have been
the only one holding it all together
Miguel go easy on here you don't belong
here you never did let me go that's
enough this isn't what we talked
about you talked about
this you
knew you you all
knew I I didn't
know how to tell
you that's why you never came to see
me miles it's for your own good who
decides that I'm not a kid
Quin that's exactly what you are you're
just a kid who has no idea what he's
doing yeah well I did lure hundreds of
spider people away from your little
clubhouse I guess he did plan this
out and I'm about to do
[Music]
this everyone keeps telling me how much
my story it's supposed to go nah I'm
going do my own
[Music]
thing
bye
[Music]